this week's episode is brought to you in
part by atlassian's ops genie
incidents happen thankfully opsgenie
empowers dev and ops teams
to plan for service disruptions and stay
in control
during incidents it also gives teams the
power to respond quickly and efficiently
to unplanned issues
and helps to notify all the right people
through a smart combination of
scheduling and escalation paths
with ops genie your next incident
doesn't stand a chance
visit oppsgenie.com to sign up to get a
free company account
and to add up to five team members
that's oppsgini.com
o-p-s-g-e-n-i-e dot com
never miss a critical alert again with
ops genie
welcome to the science podcast for
december 21st 2018.
i'm sarah crespi this is the last
podcast of the year
and we're going to celebrate with a
roundup of the top online news stories
according
to david grimm and we'll hear from news
editor tim
appenzeller he talks with megan cantwell
about this year's breakthrough of the
year and some of the runners up
and breakdowns and finally we'll have a
look back at the year in books
with jen goldbeck our books host and
science books editor
valerie thompson
[Music]
first up today we have david grimm the
online news editor for science hi dave
hey sarah so you're bringing us
some of the top 10 online news stories
for the year
that's right we have a top 10 list but
unlike other
uh science news top 10 lists you know we
tend not to focus on the most important
signs of the year we sort of leave that
for our breakthrough of the year
issue we sort of focus on our favorite
stories here and that's our sort of
a mix of our personal favorites as staff
but also
the stories that did very well traffic
or why so the stories that were audience
favorites audience favorites exactly
yeah
okay so what was your favorite you had a
big hand in picking these what's your
favorite story of the year well you know
i i i think it was probably this one
it's a really fun story it's about the
longest
straight line journey on earth and so
it's actually a water journey so the
question is if you had a boat and say
you didn't have a steering wheel on your
boat
and you wanted to be on your vote for a
very long time what is the path
you could take that would put you on the
longest straight journey on earth that
you would never have to turn the wheel
that you could just keep on going in a
straight line but it felt like forever
and this is a question that originated
on reddit and then who figured out the
answer well that's the other fun thing
about this story didn't
this is not a very traditional study for
us so there wasn't like you know a bunch
of scientists coming up with a research
project and getting funding and then it
took years and years and years
this actually started as a reddit post a
few years ago
somebody had seen a post on wikipedia
about what might be the longest straight
line
on earth so he decided to post what he
thought it was and then a couple of
scientists
saw the post and they said well we can
go ahead and try to prove this we can
use geometry and all these
very complicated high detailed maps of
earth and
that's what they went ahead and they did
and they found this path that basically
goes from southern pakistan
to northern russia that would yield a
trip of about 32
000 kilometers time to get get in your
sailboat dave that's right
so now let's talk about one that had
good
numbers so a story that performed really
well
and i mean for good reason it's also a
really interesting story i'm talking
about
the pelvis story that's right so this
was one of our most popular stories of
the year and it has to do with something
called the
obstetrical dilemma and this is this
sort of long-held evolutionary theory
that
the woman's pelvis has to be kind of
this it's
kind of a tug of war between two
evolutionary forces it can't be too
wide which would make childbirth a very
easy but it would all make
walking very difficult and obviously it
can't be too narrow for sort of the
opposite reasons
so because of that researchers have sort
of long assumed that
all pelvis shapes around the world must
be pretty similar because they have to
kind of deal with the same
horses forces right and that's not what
they found in fact they kind of found
the opposite
these researchers looked at 348
female pelvises from around the world
from 24 different parts of the world and
what they found
was that these birth cows were far from
carbon copies of each other there was a
lot of variation
and certain regions tend to have certain
shapes that other regions
didn't and so that really says that it
must not be evolutionary forces that are
sort of shaping these four
it's the ones that we thought are the
ones that we thought it must be some
other
factors that are playing a role so what
that means we're going back to the
drawing board understanding pelvis
evolution it does but it also sort of
has some
interesting implications for childbirth
because when we're trying to figure out
how the baby moves
right the birth canal things like that
it may actually inform
practices around childbirth so it's not
just kind of an interesting
story there it may actually be some real
world applications as well
okay now let's talk about i don't know
that this is my favorite but it i just
watching this story come together was so
interesting
this is the first video of living
anglerfish mating what does it look like
dave right angler fish are these really
really weird fish they
they're really creepy they live really
deep in the ocean and scientists know
almost nothing about them and that's
because
it's really hard to get much like not
even a video but
even a photograph of these guys when
they're alive if you bring them up to
the surface they can't deal with the
change of pressure and it's a really
it's kind of a a disaster and so
what's really cool about this is an
exclusive that we had we always love
this is the first video taken of angler
fish mating and it's just sort of as
bizarre as the fish themselves the
scientists sort of captured this
large female and she's got this much
smaller
male like a dwarf male that's literally
attached to her
kind of permanently attached to her body
and he sort of functions as this
sperm sac essentially so what what
happens what they think when angular
fish mate is the male
attaches to the female and actually
becomes part of the female he sort of
grows into her and almost becomes like a
part of her body
so she's supplying him with new strands
right she's eating food he can't eat
food anymore can't do anything
but he does supply sperm that she can
then lay fertile eggs right and there's
this amazing video that researchers
captured with this deepsea submersible
that showed all this and it became was
it our most popular
oh absolutely but by far our most
popular video of the year and if you
take a look at it it's not hard to see
why
and the quality really i mean it's it's
well-lit a lot of people say that it
looks like it's cgi
oh really it's just so crystal clear
which is very unexpected most of the
anglerfish photos or anglerfish corpses
yeah that you see are pretty tattered
bad shapes so this is just really
amazing yes let's
finish out the ones that we're going to
talk about we're not going to
list them all out here today this one is
about
tiny quantum engines why did this make
the cut
well you know i feel like every year
we've got a quantum physics story
on our list because first of all we do a
lot of quantum physics stories that
others don't so these tend to be kind of
exclusives for us which i just said we
like
a lot but they're also just you know the
quantum realm is such a bizarre realm
and this is another example of it this
is this a
really weird property of quantum physics
that when you try to measure something
at the quantum level you actually
change it you change its position its
distribution
and in this this new study researchers
found that they could actually
harness this change to create energy or
to create an
engine that would operate with near 100
percent efficiency okay how big is this
engine
and i should back up they actually
didn't create this they actually
theoretically created they said it's
theoretically possible and this these
are engines are
very very small this would be like the
engine the size of an atom or a molecule
not something you would necessarily put
in your car but this efficiency
is theory is amazing even though it's
sort of theoretical when you think of a
car
the engines of the the engine is about
25
efficient right so if you've got
something that's 100 efficient you can
imagine
that you know you could create these
really maybe
swarm of tiny tiny molecular machines
now the big question is what would you
use them for right i mean really how
hard would it be to create these things
in real life but just the
the science around this the physics
around this is really really fascinating
to dig into to figure out like
how something like this would even be
possible in the first place okay dave
and as i mentioned we're not going to
reveal
the rest of the top ten so please go to
the site including our most popular
store of the year
but one thing that struck me looking at
this list is what is
not there and that is a cat story
or a dog story which is just shocking so
you know we had a pretty popular story
on viking cats why didn't that make
things
yeah and just like we have a quantum
physics story every year i feel like
we've got a cat or a dog story every
year just because
i personally love those stories also the
stories tend to do very well
so we had uh last week we had a story
about viking cats and this was another
exclusive for us this is a story about
how cats seem to have changed size
gotten bigger during the viking era
this was an analysis of a bunch of cat
bones that were found some of these cats
were sort of skinned for their fur
and so there's a lot of interesting
history here too
the story actually ended up being a lot
of fun it became very popular but
all that was sort of happening while we
were putting together top 10 lists so
did that time
white squeak in there but it's a story
that was a lot of fun and i highly
encourage listeners to go check
and i'm going to expect at least one cat
or dog story next year i hope so
all right thank you so much dave thanks
sir david grimm is the online news
editor for science
read the rest of the top online news
stories at news.sciencemag.org
stay tuned for megan cantwell's
interview with news editor tim
appenzeller on this year's breakthrough
of the year
[Music]
this week's episode is brought to you in
part by atlassian's ops genie
incidents happen and they require
complex coordination
between operations and software
development teams who are putting out
fires
every day that's why getting alerts
immediately
is critical thankfully there's ops genie
by atlassian
ops genie empowers dev and ops teams to
plan for service disruptions and stay
in control during incidents it also
gives teams the power to respond quickly
and efficiently to unplanned issues
and helps to notify all the right people
through a smart combination of
scheduling and escalation
paths that account for things like time
zones holidays
better yet oppsgeni allows for deep
flexibility
and how when and where alerts are
deployed with over 200 integrations like
jira
amazon cloudwatch datadog new relic and
more
plus it tracks all activity and provides
useful insights
to improve future incident responses
with ops genie your next incident
doesn't stand a chance
visit oppsgeni.com to sign up to get a
free company account and add up to five
team members
that's oppsgenie.com o p s g e n
i e dot com never miss a critical alert
again
with ops genie
several months ago science compiled an
extensive list of significant
discoveries and advancements that have
occurred throughout 2018.
ultimately that list was whittled down
to a short list of nine runners-up
and one winner the breakthrough of the
year i'm here with news editor of
science tim
appenzeller to talk through a few of
these advancements
hey tim hey megan so let's get started
with one of the runners up which was
that the first
rna interference or rnai drug entered
the market this year
how exactly does this drug treat
diseases
what it does is it blocks the genetic
message from the gene
to the cell's protein machinery
so it actually gets right at the root of
the disease process
rnai was discovered 20 years ago but it
took a while for it to reach the market
well it works through small rnas
that trigger the breakdown of this
message that i mentioned
and the problem was getting those small
rnas to the right spot in the body
so in the future we could probably see
other diseases that it's marketed for as
well
i think we'll see more drugs following
the same approach yes
another one on the list was gains for
the metoo movement within the sciences
and what changes were catalyzed within
science organizations and research
institutions as a result of this
movement
well several big science organizations
began developing
or at least talking about mechanisms to
take away honors from people who have
been
found guilty of sexual harassment so
this is the kind of thing that the metoo
movement has been pushing for for some
time
now it appears to be starting to happen
one of my personal favorites was the
discovery of a 31 kilometer wide impact
crater under greenland
but they're not sure exactly when it hit
it could have a range of anywhere
between
12 000 to 100 000 years ago when it hit
what would have been the
implications for the climate and life on
earth at that moment
well it would have melted an awful lot
of ice and if this had happened at a key
moment about 13 000 years ago
it could have caused a climate event
called the younger dryas when the world
which was
warming after the end of the last ice
age suddenly returned to glacial
conditions and
the trigger of this has been a mystery
this crater raises the possibility that
the impact if it happened 13 000 years
ago
could have unleashed this flood into the
north atlantic which would have shut
down a set of currents
and triggered the climate shift so
scientists breakthrough of the year in
2016 was the detection of gravitational
waves
a messenger from a distant universe and
one of the runners up from this year is
related to that discovery
a new type of messenger neutrinos were
detected deep in the ice of the south
pole
what are these particles and where did
they come from
so these are very lightweight particles
that are
really hard to detect but they've set up
this
detector which is basically a cubic
kilometer of ice
threaded with light detectors it's very
clear ice and so when a neutrino flies
through it it can sometimes trigger a
faint flash of light
and from the direction of this flash
they can figure out where the neutrino
came from
this year they traced one neutrino back
to
a blazar which is a kind of very bright
galaxy with a black hole at its center
it's the first neutrino to be traced
to this kind of source outside our
galaxy
and it suggests that these blazars might
be the source of other high-energy
particles like the high-energy cosmic
rays that sometimes strike the earth
so now moving past these runners up to
the breakthrough of the year which was
development cell by cell and being able
to observe cell development wasn't just
one discovery necessarily but a
combination of technologies working
together
could you explain what advances are
encompassed within this one breakthrough
so it's really three techniques first
the ability to
extract thousands of cells from a
developing embryo
then the ability to sequence their
rna which tells you what genes are
active
cell by cell you can get basically the
genetic activity in each cell
and then there are techniques for
tracing cell lineages within
embryos so the rna sequencing gives you
a snapshot of what's going on in an
embryo
if you can trace each cell's descendants
you can see where that type of cell
how it contributes to the building of
the embryo so you put it all together
and you get this picture in space and
time
of how each cell kind of assumes its
identity and gives rise to new cells
to build an embryo what organisms and
organs development where researchers
able to see through these techniques
well they've looked at a bunch of them
this the big advance this year was
moving these techniques into vertebrates
animals like ourselves really zebrafish
salamander limbs and several others
besides tracking development what were
other ways that researchers used single
cell rna sequencing
it's revealed things about the
development of disease
so you can look at tissues you can
identify the variety of cells that
make up those tissues and you can watch
cells
change as a disease develops for example
a cancer
what do you think we can expect to see
in the future as a result of this
breakthrough
well i think deeper understanding of the
way
organisms develop the way limbs grow the
way
and the way diseases develop and that
undoubtedly will lead to
medical treatments so although we had
these breakthroughs of the year we also
had breakdowns could you go over
what that means well these are
science-related developments
that are not good yeah that really were
steps
back you know we think of science as a
march of progress well it isn't always
and so
our major breakdown of the year was
really the the gap between what science
is telling us
about climate change and the urgency of
it and what policy makers are doing or
not doing
one kind of related advancement that
would be the attribution science
made gains yeah yeah no we see more
clearly
than ever that climate change is taking
place and that
it is getting worse fast and that it is
affecting
the world we live in in very powerful
ways the you know
succession of powerful hurricanes fires
in california
heat waves and far northern latitudes
all of these can be tied
you know to greater lesser extent to
climate change
were there any other breakdowns included
in the list yes
so late in the year there was the claim
that an embryo had been
genetically modified and then implanted
and
brought to term so babies have been born
that have been genetically modified
in ways that they will pass on to their
children and this happened without the
kind of debate
and without the kinds of safeguards that
most
scientists and ethicists believe are
necessary
and without proper you know
consideration of the health risks
to these children all right thank you so
much dan you're welcome
pleasure that was tim appenzeller news
editor of science
if you want to read more about the
breakthrough of 2018 the runners-up
and the breakdowns of the year visit
sciencemag.org
news keep listening for our roundup of
the year in books
and some suggestions for books that you
might want to buy as gifts for the
holiday season
hi everyone welcome to the book segment
of the podcast this is jen goldbeck and
we're doing the year
in review i'm here with valerie thompson
and we're going to talk about our
favorite books
and maybe our least favorite books that
would be easier if we had a couple
cocktails
i suppose uh things we remembered and
give you some recommendations if you're
looking for last minute holiday gifts
so jen you interviewed 11 authors for us
this year in 2018.
one of them i'm thinking of is
especially uh timely here at the end of
the year do you want to talk about that
one
yeah so we did the perfectionist by
simon winchester who is
just a wonderful interview a charming
guy who's written a lot of great books
and we had a really long conversation
and i think part of it that didn't make
it into his segment on the podcast
you know this year is the end of the
kilogram being defined by that lump of
metal that i think is in france
and that's an example of this really
precision engineering and we're getting
rid of that and replacing it with a much
more accurate and scientific definition
but he talked about how you know there's
something a little sad and like
us as humans not being able to make that
reference kilogram anymore so i thought
that that was
interesting i'd forgotten he said that
and then in the news just in the last
few weeks we've heard
the kilogram is going away and you see
this beautiful little kilogram
it's gonna be locked into a museum and
not worth anything anymore
and that that was a nice tie back to his
book on you know how we can create these
very finely milled
things and and how beautiful human
precision can be i love that i love that
because it's just this kind of like
human story behind this very
precise surreal kind of thing all right
so
can you talk about did did any of the
books really draw you in was there any
that was on a specific topic that you
were really intrigued by
yeah we did clean meat by paul shapiro
which is about lab grown meat
and i was really excited when you gave
me this book because i'm a vegetarian
and uh oh all right so it was really
interesting to look at
how's that industry going it's much
farther along than
i thought it was and also talking about
what are the ways that we can get people
to do this so
you know one of the examples he said is
that a lot of people are going to be
skeezed out eating
meat that was grown in a lab but leather
would be a really interesting way to do
this skin is very easy to grow
relatively you know if you're going in
the lab there we could replace
the leather that we're using that's
coming from animals and replace it with
something grown in a lab
that's not the end game you want to
replace the whole animal
needing to be killed but it was really
interesting
because it brought together this kind of
commercialization
and kind of human component of it in
addition to
all the other stuff so i thought it was
really interesting you also have
favorite book
this year i do have a favorite book the
book that
was kind of my favorite book that we
reviewed not on the podcast but in the
magazine is a book called the feather
thief
beauty obsession and the natural history
heist of the century
by kirk wallace johnson the book is
centered around a theft that occurred at
a natural history museum in the uk
in 2009. in the early hours of june 23rd
a man named edwin wrist broke into the
natural history museum at tring
and filled a roller suitcase with 299
bird specimens
as the story comes out we learn that he
is a member of an elite community of
victorian fly tires
flies being the brightly colored lures
that people used to catch fish
and his plan was to dismantle these bird
specimens
and sell the feathers to other fly-tying
enthusiasts
so that he could buy a new flute because
did i mention
uh that he was a flautist who had
earlier
that day performed at the london royal
academy of music
this is just gets more insane the more
you talk yeah it's like a crazy story so
you know he ends up getting caught and
you know instead of getting this money
for a new flute he ends up being
sentenced to 12 months in prison and
he receives a fine what happened to the
birds well that's the thing like
once these specimens were removed from
the museum
and once they were separated from the
little tags that are on them that tell
you like what the specimen is and when
it was collected and by whom
they don't have any more scientific
value so even the specimens that were
recovered
those lose their value a lot of them
were dismantled
just the agony of like what has been
lost to science and so
it's a really interesting i think i'm
like kind of like a true crime
person too so this is why that that
story
really really resonates with me i think
sounds fantastic
so recommendations woman with the
shelves and shelves full of books
okay i'm going to recommend philip
moriarty's when the uncertainty
principle goes to 11
or how to explain quantum physics with
heavy metal it's a great premise
the idea is that music is an ideal
platform for introducing concepts like
the physics of waves and harmonics and
resonance and
energy conservation and so he kind of
like
does these cute analogies where he'll he
shows
how physics famous double slit
experiment and
eddie van halen's brown sound both share
this key feature which is waveform
interference
he looks at the statistical mechanisms
of crowds in a mosh pit
um he compares the sound of the big bang
with the loudest heavy metal concert
so very fun physics is not my strong
suit so i'm always kind of on the hunt
for things that can
lead me to it slowly i guess
so i thought this book was really fun
for the politically minded
in the audience i'm going to recommend
liliana mason's uncivil agreement
how politics became our identity so this
is like a a very uh
kind of relevant one for our time so it
looks at how
political polarization became such a
prominent feature of our
political system she kind of argues that
there's become more and more overlap
between our other identities so a
person's race their religious
affiliation
whether they think of themselves as
liberal conservative
and then like whether we consider
ourselves to be a democrat
or a republican and so when we start
identifying psychologically with a
particular party
we start to experience this animosity
towards the other team
and a desire for our own team to win
which kind of
becomes an end unto itself even if we
don't
have particularly strong feelings for
the the issue so it's it's
a really interesting look at this thing
that we're all kind of wondering about
and
she does have some ideas for how we
might try to mitigate those
oh that's good yeah i hope that works
yeah i hope so too
i hope somebody takes them to heart so
you had a recommendation for gif
for a gift this year too so i i love to
do combination gifts and i think we
talked about that when we did our year
in the review last year where i think we
had a wine book and i'm like oh it'd be
great you give a bottle of wine and then
this book
so this year i recommend you get a
bottle of lysol disinfectant and then
this book
never home alone from microbes to
millipedes camel crickets and honeybees
the natural history of where we live by
rob dunn
uh this is a book that i got sent from
the publisher i just looked it up on
amazon
today it's the number one bestseller in
ichthyology
on amazon which is a pretty cool
distinction
[Laughter]
but it's sort of about how we like
aspire to have these
super clean pristine homes and how
they're totally not
and there's all of these bugs and
organisms and stuff living in there with
us
one of my favorite examples from it that
it i think opens with towards the
beginning
is talking about this research lab where
they're looking at these
organisms that live in like thermal
vents these super high temperatures
and how we've never really been able to
find them before because
our regular lab temperatures are so cold
even our hot lab temperatures are so
cold that they couldn't live
and then you'd put them at these hot
temperatures and oh they were there and
then we started learning about them
and in the lab they're like maybe
they're actually all over the place and
not just in these thermal vents and
started looking at like
their coffee pot which didn't have any
but other places where there's hot water
and they found them there
so there actually are these what seem
like really exotic organisms like oh
they're in these thermal events but
actually they live in all these crazy
environments that we create in these
small places around where we live
and talks about how our weird household
obsessions actually can kind of drive
evolution in some of these
microorganisms but yeah i think that'd
make a nice
gift with some raid or some lysol which
it just
isn't nice i don't know is that like
embracing or rejecting like the premise
of the book
this is jen's last episode as our
host she's been hosting this segment for
us for the last
two years so i just want to say thank
you
on behalf of all of us at science this
has been it's been great to work with
you
i've loved listening to your interviews
you've done a great job
and we're really going to miss you i've
had a super fun time
i love that i now have a couple shelves
of books that i've reviewed for science
and uh as a fiction reader by choice
it has been a really great opportunity
to find like the best new science books
that are out there
and then also get to have my own
personal conversations with the people
who are writing them so i've had a great
time
great i'm glad we converted you yeah he
did i'm now reading all sorts of new
ones
all right great thanks everyone have a
very merry christmas and happy hanukkah
and happy new year and happy holidays
and all those things
and uh someone else will be back with
you in the new year with more books
just a reminder that this episode has
been brought to you in part by
atlassian's ops genie
incidents happen thankfully ops genie
empowers dev and ops teams to plan for
service disruptions and stay in control
during incidents it also gives teams the
power to respond quickly and efficiently
to unplanned issues
and helps to notify all the right people
through a smart combination of
scheduling and escalation paths
with ops genie your next incident
doesn't stand a chance
visit oppsgenie.com to sign up to get a
free company account
and add up to five team members that's
o-p-s-g-e-n-i-e
dot com never miss a appsgenie.com alert
again
with opsgenie
and that concludes this edition of the
science podcast
if you have any comments or suggestions
for the show write to us
at sciencepodcast aaas.org you can
subscribe to the show
anywhere you get your podcasts or you
can listen on the science website that's
sciencemag.org podcast to place an ad
on the podcast contact midroll.com the
show was produced by sarah crespy and
megan cantwell
and edited by potagy jeffrey cook
composed the music
on behalf of science magazine and its
publisher aaas
thanks for joining us